de la santé
monsieur ministre madame la rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons cet
après-midi les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par l'audition de
Monsieur Olivier Véran sa qualité
d'ancien ministre de la Solidarité et de
la santé je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre de vous êtes mobilisés notre
mission aujourd'hui n'est pas de revenir
sur votre action pour faire face à la
pandémie mais de regarder par de la les
vagues pour reprendre le titre du récit
que vous avez consacré à la gestion de
la crise covid nous savons tous que
celle-ci a largement fait passer les
autres impératifs de santé si ce n'est
au second plan en tout cas sur un plan
un peu parallèle nous avons néanmoins
souhaité vous entendre à double titre
d'abord parce que si la pandémie a
grandement contribue à la gravation des
ruptures d'approvisionnement médicament
celle-ci ne date pas de la propagation
du Sark of 2 votre prédécesseur avait
établi une feuille de route 2019-2022
pour lutter contre les pénuries et
améliorer la disponibilité des
médicaments en France celle-ci
comportait 28 actions ordonnées selon
quatre axes le premier était celui de
promouvoir la transparence et la qualité
de l'information afin de rétablir la
confiance et la fluidité entre tous les
acteurs du professionnel de santé au
patient le second était lutter contre
les pénuries de médicaments par de
nouvelles actions de prévention et de
gestion sur l'ensemble des circuits du
médicament
le troisième était renforcé la
coordination nationale et la coopération
européenne pour mieux prévenir les
pénuries de médicaments et enfin le
quatrième mettre en place une nouvelle
une nouvelle gouvernance nationale
je pense que nous allons pouvoir revenir
sur ces quatre axes qui restent
d'actualité nous serons tous d'accord
pour considérer que le contexte
sanitaire de début 2020 afin 2022 ne
pouvait pas bouleverser les perspectives
de réalisation de ces objectifs pour
autant toutes les actions n'ont pas été
laissées de côté et des dispositions
législatives comme réglementaires sont
intervenus pendant que vous étiez en
charge de la santé au gouvernement nous
serons évidemment attentifs au bilan que
vous en dressez aujourd'hui par ailleurs
si elle ne constitue pas notre mission
l'étude de la gestion de la pandémie
n'est pas sans lien avec la lutte contre
les pénuries je pense par exemple au
début de la crise à la question des
stocks de masques en particulier là on
parle des dispositifs médicaux et l'idée
d'étendre la date de péremption des
médicaments ruptures a été évoquée par
plusieurs personnes que nous avons
évoquées c'est une question que nous
avions évoquée pour les masques et qui a
été évoqué par ailleurs la FDA du reste
aux États-Unis et a proposé de répondre
sur certaines pénuries par par
ce sujet de de décaler la date de
péremption
l'autre l'autre élément évidemment et
celui du témoignage aussi de la gestion
en urgence de la pénurie des médicaments
anesthésiques comme le propofol les
curare que vous avez eu à gérer et nous
témoignerez de la façon dont vous avez
vécu cette période très particulière ou
un usage imprévu exceptionnel si l'on en
faut a dû nous obliger à faire face et
donc à mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de mesures qui restent
exceptionnels mais qui pour autant
répondu en tout cas sur le moment à
cette question de la pénurie le
troisième sujet celui de la gestion
européenne de la commande de médicaments
qui a été vraiment aussi un élément
particulier de la covid mais qui pour
l'instant qui pour qui pour autant
fait porter un regard différent sur les
questions de sanitaires au niveau
européen avec ce fameux entre guillemets
le terme trivial le paquet médicament
qui est sorti
là au niveau européen récemment et la
santé de nouveau devenu une question
européenne avec cette question des
pénuries de médicaments dont c'est
emparé les maps puisque elle a vu dans
ses compétences cette question des
pénuries arrivées et donc nous
souhaitons nous attendons de vous de
porter le regard que vous portez sur ce
qui s'est passé les mesures en urgence
qui sont mises en place celles qui
pourraient être utile en dehors des
phases critiques puisque là malgré la
fameuse triple
triple épidémie de cet hiver il ne reste
pas moins que lors de la mission
sénatoriale en 2018 les pénuries étaient
évaluées entre 700 et 800 médicaments
alors pénurie tension tout ça bougeait
très vite pour éviter quand même sur des
pénuries réelles pour un certain nombre
de médicaments et là on estime entre
2500 et 3000 ces médicaments qui sont en
tension en pénurie avec pour certains
comme les corticoïdes en goutte pour
je le jure je vous remercie monsieur
vous avez la parole pour votre
intervention linéaire madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur madame
et Messieurs les vice-présidente et
vice-présidents Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs merci pour
cette
invitation convocation en commission
d'enquête permettez-moi en introduction
à cette audition de rappeler que je suis
reçu et vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui en
ma qualité d'anciens ministre de la
Santé ça fait bizarre de voir ça sur un
chevalet et non pas au titre de mes
fonctions actuelles de porte-parole du
gouvernement aussi je concentrerai mon
intervention et tout à fait je
contenterai mon intervention et mes
réponses au prérogatives qui furent les
miennes et sur la période actuelle aux
seules annonces publiques faites par la
première ministre et les ministres en
charge
vous comprendrez aisément que je ne
saurais apporter des éléments de réponse
sur des dossiers qui entre aujourd'hui
plus dans mon portefeuille ministériel
cela est en précisé je remercie le Sénat
d'assurer ce travail d'enquête car il
est toujours utile de se pencher sur
cette question qui certes n'est pas
nouvelle mais qui est qui a été au cœur
de l'actualité cet hiver elle est encore
aujourd'hui elle ne sera peut-être
encore hélas tout autant demain il faut
en croire en effet il faut croire en
effet et je parle ici en tant
qu'observateur que les pénuries
viendront à s'accélérer j'en veux pour
preuve différents éléments d'abord le
vieillissement de la population à
l'échelle de notre pays et de l'Europe
on vit plus longtemps c'est une bonne
chose mais on vit depuis longtemps avec
des maladies chroniques on a appris à
vivre avec ce qui est aussi une bonne
chose mais pour y arriver nous
consommons des médicaments de plus en
plus de médicaments j'y viendrai tout à
l'heure trop de médicaments
la demande va continuer d'augmenter ces
mécanique
l'offre qui répond à cette demande c'est
celle de l'industrie qui part nature à
un impact sur l'environnement j'en
parlerai tout à l'heure parce que quand
on parle d'introduire des usines de
production de médicaments j'avais eu
l'occasion de le dire à des
parlementaires lorsque j'étais ministre
en charge on parle d'usine qui sont
souvent pétrochimiques avec des sites
césaux donc tout le monde veut qu'on
produise des médicaments dans le pays
mais c'est plus compliqué de trouver les
endroits où l'implanter et que ça fasse
consensus et on peut le comprendre sans
que sans oublier sans omettre le fait
que la transition écologique nous oblige
aussi à faire des choix très raisonnés
en matière de production industrielle
j'aborde même pas la question du coût de
production j'espère que c'est
conjoncturel et la consommation
énergétique de ces industries tente à
peser fortement sur le dynamisme de
l'offre surtout lorsqu'elle se fait
appris constant et j'y reviendrai là
aussi nous avons donc d'un côté une
offre qui pourrait être contrainte
pendant que la demande elle accélèrerait
c'était là le scénario idéal si je peux
me permettre le mot pour que des
pénuries continuent de se multiplier
surtout je souhaiterais avant d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet apporter une autre
précision qui me semble de taille il ne
faudrait pas laisser croire à nos
concitoyens que le gouvernement découvre
le sujet d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit en
introduction et je vous en remercie nous
avons commencé à voir la croissance des
pénuries de médicaments car nous avons
commencé à les mesurer
les déclarations obligatoires auprès de
l'ANSM pour les tensions et les ruptures
de médicaments ont donné à avoir un état
au vrai d'une situation qui était sans
doute très imparfaitement mesuré jusqu'à
jusqu'à lors des choses ont été faites
en partie lorsque j'étais ministre mais
pas seulement en ma qualité de
parlementaire déjà j'ai eu à connaître
des textes et réflexions portées par
d'autres gouvernements que celui auquel
j'appartiens aujourd'hui si bien qu'en
matière de lutte contre les pénuries de
médicaments la France dispose d'un cadre
juridique particulièrement robuste et
protecteur que nombre de nos voisins
nous envient
j'interviendrai aujourd'hui autour de
trois points non pas 4 madame la
Présidente mais trois points qui me
semblent aussi bien traduire le sens de
mon action en tant que ministre de la
Santé quatre des éléments de réflexion
et de prospection précieux à garder à
l'esprit pour comprendre la situation du
médicament aujourd'hui d'abord je vous
présenterai la feuille de route
j'aborderai la feuille de route
2019-2022 que j'ai piloté en tant que
ministre et participer à enrichir avant
d'être ministre lorsque j'étais
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale ensuite et c'est une évidence
mais je reviendrai avec vous sur la
crise du covid-19 et dans quelle mesure
elle a été dans sa dimension sanitaire
comme économique un accélérateur et un
catalyseur autant de la pénurie du
médicament que dans notre feuille de
route pour lutter contre la pénurie
enfin je terminerai sur des
considérations à moyen et long terme sur
l'avenir du médicament de sa production
à son recyclage en passant naturellement
par son usage en France et en Europe
commençons donc par le commencement la
feuille de route
2019-2022 elle a été pensée lancée dans
un contexte qui est différent en tout de
ce que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
après avoir traversé la crise sanitaire
dans le caractère inédit dans l'histoire
contemporaine n'a peut-être eu des gale
que sa violence pour nos sociétés
pourtant déjà je m'en souviens sur les
bords de l'Assemblée nationale le sujet
des pénuries de médicaments étaient un
sujet de préoccupation en 2019 le
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe s'est
emparé du sujet en effet on relève qu'en
10 ans de 2008 à 2018 les signalements
de pénurie ont été multipliés par 20 ce
qui était un fer rarissime semblait pour
des raisons que vous connaissez mais sur
lesquelles nous pourrons revenir devenir
une tendance de fond durable en France
et en Europe je vais d'ailleurs là une
assise la situation et les constats ne
se limitent pas au seul hexagone
l'ensemble de nos voisins sont aussi
concernés
face à l'enjeu l'ambition et la volonté
d'anticipation du Premier ministre se
sont traduites en acte dans la feuille
de route ambitieuse qui a été pilotée
par Agnès Buzyn puis par votre serviteur
cette feuille de route est visée ainsi
quatre objectifs prioritaires on y vient
promouvoir la transparence et la qualité
de l'information améliorer la gestion et
la sécurisation de l'ensemble de la
chaîne du médicament renforcer la
coopération européenne mettre en place
une nouvelle gouvernance nationale au
service de ces objectifs 28 actions ont
été déployées dans le contexte contraint
que vous connaissez 7 groupes de travail
se sont régulièrement réunis pour
proposer des mesures concrètes je vous
ferai pas la litanie de l'ensemble des
actions menées dans le cadre de la
feuille de route mais je me concentrer
sur la principale retenue comme un des
temps fort des politiques
gouvernementales dans l'anticipation des
pénuries de médicaments la question des
stocks
nous avons fixé une obligation de
constitution d'un stock de sécurité
permanent de deux mois pour tous les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs et d'une semaine pour les autres
médicaments avec possibilité de contrôle
et donc de sanction
ce décret 10 stock a été arraché je peux
vous le dire de haute lutte auprès de
l'Europe et j'espère aujourd'hui que ce
dispositif sera repris à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne à la hauteur des
critères français de manière à avoir un
poids plus fort vis-à-vis des
laboratoires et traduire une vision
partagée de l'accès aux médicaments pour
les patients européens j'étais
rapporteur général j'étais intervenu
pour que ces stocks soient constitués à
l'échelle du territoire européen je vais
pas vous dire de bêtises parce qu'on est
sous serment et il me semble que
l'unanimité n'était pas loin si tentait
qu'elle n'était pas au rendez-vous
c'était un combat parlementaire que
j'avais mené pour être tout à fait
exhaustif après avoir été amené à
repousser des amendements je crois lors
du PLFSS précédent parce que c'était des
amendements qui étaient inspirés
d'associations qui s'étaient mobilisés
et que je salue parce qu'elles ont été
déterminantes la rédaction ne permettait
pas d'être conforme aux droits européens
je m'étais engagé à revenir l'année
d'après avec une disposition cette
fois-ci conforme c'était une bataille
non pas parlementaire parce que je crois
qu'il y avait quand même consensus même
si certains députés trouvaient que on
aurait pu aller plus loin que cela mais
ça a été aussi une bataille pour prendre
le décret pour le faire accepter au
niveau de la Commission européenne je
vous dis ça parce que c'est aussi une
manière pardon d'illustrer mon
application sur le sujet et ma vigilance
a anticipé ces pénuries alors je n'étais
pas encore Ministre en charge la seconde
mesure d'ampleur a été une refonte de
l'ensemble de la procédure des plantes
gestion des pénuries par la NSM afin de
renforcer nos capacités d'adaptation par
ailleurs dans cette bataille de
l'anticipation vous le savez l'accès à
l'information est cruciale aussi le
déploiement du logiciel des perructures
par l'Ordre des pharmaciens que je salue
et remercie à participer pleinement à
cet effort développer des 2013 ce
logiciel est maintenant utilisé dans la
quasi-totalité des officines en France
mon objectif communiste était clair que
les Français soient les premiers à avoir
accès aux médicaments lorsqu'il y avait
des innovations et qu'il était et qu'il
soit les derniers à en manquer
la deuxième partie de mon propos est
naturellement orientée autour de la
crise covid-19 car vous le savez à la
bousculé le déploiement de notre feuille
de route en particulier et la planète
entière en général en effet la crise a
eu deux effets sur les pénuries des
médicaments un effet micro la feuille de
route était un cadre qu'il fallait
dépasser et un effet macro la mise à
l'arrêt d'une partie de la planète
allait avoir un effet certain sur la
production mondiale de médicaments
lorsque je me réfère à l'effet des
micros je veux bien évidemment éviter
tout malentendu la crise n'a pas eu pour
conséquence de rendre la feuille de
route obsolète bien au contraire la
crise a accéléré son déploiement et ses
ambitions dans le même temps il a fallu
s'en dégager parfois pour mener des
actions complémentaires face à des
pénuries mondiales et face à une
succession d'événements divers et variés
à l'instar de la pénurie de carton qui
de prime abord n'est pas un événement de
nature à créer une pénurie de
médicaments et pourtant
par ailleurs qui dit crise dit aussi
reprise la France a accompagné cet élan
ainsi dans le cadre de France relance le
ministère de la Santé a travaillé en
étroite collaboration avec la Direction
Générale des Entreprises la DGE depuis
2020 à la mise en place de dispositifs
visant à redévelopper les productions en
France pour réduire la dépendance
extra-européenne 150 projets ont été
soutenus 1,3 milliards d'euros
d'investissements industriels 650
millions d'aides d'État dédiés être
d'État qui s'élève à 1,5 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre du dispositif
France 2030 grâce au dérogations
européennes au titre des pieds et
pardonner un instant pour chevinisme
mais nous sommes fiers en Isère de nous
préparer à réaccueillir la production de
paracétamol suite à l'engagement du
président de la République en juin 2020
dans le cadre de France relance surtout
et ce constat sera la parfaite
transition vers mon troisième point la
crise a définitivement confirmée que la
politique du médicament devait se penser
et être traduite au niveau européen pour
qu'elle soit pleinement efficace
je reviens par là à la dernière partie
de mon propos donc autour de piste de
réflexion d'abord la solution est
européenne je serai sans tension à ce
sujet il faut surtout pas se tromper de
combat la solution ne peut être que
européenne pourquoi parce que les
industriels ne produisent pas qu'en
France parce que la production de
médicaments n'est pas soumise au même
aléas au même orbes et critères d'un
pays à un autre comme nous avons mené la
bataille du vaccin en européen nous
devons mener celle de
l'approvisionnement de médicaments à
cette même échelle si la France venait à
poser un cadre d'obligation nationale
bien trop strict vis-à-vis de ses
voisins nous prendrions le risque d'une
perte de compétitivité qui nous
fragiliserait dans l'accès aux
médicaments c'est d'ailleurs le sens de
l'engagement pris par les deux ministres
messieurs Braun et Lescure au service
d'une nouvelle stratégie en matière de
prévention et de gestion des pénuries
ensuite il faut viser la sobriété dans
la consommation des médicaments il faut
garder à l'esprit que la France fait
partie des pays en Europe et dans le
monde où la consommation de médicaments
et la plus forte il me semble qu'une des
solutions se trouve dans la réduction de
notre consommation de médicaments à
travers plusieurs leviers d'abord la
dispensation à l'unité permise par la
loi anti-gaspillage pour une économie
circulaire je salue d'ailleurs
l'engagement c'était brune Poirson qui
était secrétaire d'État à la transition
écologique à l'époque en faveur de ce
dispositif qui est hélas aujourd'hui
trop peu employé je m'étais d'ailleurs
mobilisé comme député pour les
antibiotiques parce que les
antibiotiques c'était quelque chose qui
s'y prêtait peut-être davantage que des
médicaments qui peuvent être parfois
conditionnés un des boîtes plus
importantes pour des gens qui sont
atteints de maladies chroniques des
expérimentations ont été conduites mais
on voit que de la théorie à l'acte c'est
assez compliqué on vous parlera de la
sérialisation de la sécurisation etc qui
fait que cette idée excellente pour
mémoire je crois que c'était l'idée la
plus souvent remonter dans le cadre de
la grande marche de la campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 et que le
passage la réalisation en pratique ce
Heart a beaucoup de contraintes
notamment normatives ensuite
l'augmentation de la maîtrise
médicalisée est un autre levier pour
cela il faut accompagner un changement
de culture toute consultation médicale
ne doit pas nécessairement être conclu
par les prescriptions d'un médicament
enfin il faut renforcer notre vigilance
sur la prescription à tout va
d'antibiotiques ça demeure une priorité
notamment en renforçant notre capacité
et notre recours à des tests permettant
de définir tout simplement si une
infection est virale ou bactérienne on a
développé les trodes tests rapides en
pharmacie il faut sans doute aller plus
loin dans la capacité des Français être
capable de voir par eux-mêmes s'il
relève d'une ordonnance d'antibiotiques
ou non je ferai peut-être plaisir à
Madame la rapporteur Laurence Cohen en
citant hors de mon texte je crois que
c'était ivan Ilitch qui avait écrit un
ouvrage il y a de cela 50 ans qui
s'appelle Nemesis médical et qui
racontait par le menu comment à force
d'expliquer aux gens que la santé ne
leur appartenait plus enfin l'évaluation
de leur santé de leur appartenait plus
mais appartenait à des experts on les
avait éloignés d'un certain nombre de
connaissances pourtant fondamentales qui
doivent permettre à des citoyens
français d'être capable de davantage
s'autonomiser dans la gestion d'un
certain nombre de maladies dites
courantes je ferme la parenthèse il
vanillic
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez au
dictionnaire la délégué j'ai pu c'est
une déléguer ministérielle à
l'antibio-résistance qui fait un travail
formidable moi que je recevais tous les
trois mois comme ministres dans mon
bureau et qui a obtenu déjà des
résultats importants en matière de
réduction de prescription d'antibiotique
ainsi il s'agit que les médecins
prescrivent moins que les pharmaciens
délivre moins et que les Français
consomme mieux de la sobriété en santé
en somme il s'agit pas d'une punition
s'agit pas d'un aveu de faiblesse au
contraire on doit faire évoluer nos
usages pour viser juste consommation ni
trop ni trop peu des médicaments dans
notre pays
troisièmement pas de médicaments sans
industrie son industrie verte évidemment
cette question de l'approvisionnement
médicament n'est pas la seule
prérogative des ministres de la santé
elle est éminemment industrielle et
pardonnez-moi d'enfoncer des portes
ouvertes mais je pense qu'elle est
cruciale en effet je faisais référence à
l'impact environnemental de cette
industrie en introduction nous parlons
souvent de réimplantation dans nos
territoires de notre production de
relocalisation d'usine qui aujourd'hui
pour la plupart situé sur le continent
asiatique mais nous le savons la
situation n'est pas aussi évidente ou
simple que cela
la question du futur du médicament est
donc intimement liée à celle du
verdissement de notre industrie et ce
d'autant que les pays actuellement
producteurs de matières premières sont
eux aussi en train d'opérer des
changements de paradigme au regard de
l'urgence écologique en 30 ans la
production de 80% des principes actifs a
été délocalisé en Asie 80% des principes
actifs nécessaires à fabriquer des
médicaments y compris ceux d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur pour la population
mondiale sont concentrées dans quelques
pays d'Asie quand sera-t-il lorsque ces
pays ne voudront plus produire ses
principes actifs ou lorsque des tensions
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver à
l'avenir on le souhaite pas les tensions
géopolitiques pourraient conduire à des
pressions sur ces chaînes de délivrance
des principes actifs au reste du monde
je m'interroge avec vous c'est 30 ans de
politique de désindustrialisation dans
le monde occidental ce sont accompagnés
d'une prise de risque que j'estime
majeure et madame la Présidente vous
parliez tout à l'heure des masques
j'en ferai l'analogie un moment donné il
a été considéré que la production de
masques délocalisée en Asie en
l'occurrence en Chine et dans une seule
quasiment province chinoise était de
nature à réduire les coûts et permettre
d'alimenter toute la planète en masque
dont acte enfin avec le recul on peut
quand même se dire que c'est bien de
garder un peu de souveraineté le mot
n'est pas moche au contraire et vous
savez qui tient à cœur du président de
la République
quatrièmement quel juste prix pour le
médicament j'ai pas eu l'idée la
question j'en terminerai par là sans
pour autant vouloir réduire ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui à une question
pécuniaire mais force est de constater
que la question du prix du médicament
c'est un corollaire de sa pénurie
j'assume de formuler cette interrogation
de votre commission d'enquête là vous
n'avons nous pas maintenu le prix des
médicaments trop bas trop longtemps la
mission annoncée par la première
ministre Elisabeth borne sur la fixation
du prix du médicament rendra bientôt ses
conclusions il nous faudra
collectivement y être à l'écoute car il
me semble qu'une partie de l'enjeu une
partie de l'enjeu réside ici nos
concitoyens le constatent aujourd'hui
tout augmente du beurre en passant par
la baguette ou le steak congelé tout
augmente sauf le médicament et ce alors
que le prix de l'électricité le cours
mondial des matières premières eux ont
grimpé en flèche notamment suite au long
confinement de la Chine et l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie lorsque les prix
sont administrés c'est l'industriel qui
absorbe le choc et cette réflexion que
je vous livre n'est en rien une
intervention au soutien au laboratoire
je crois que mon passé parlementaire et
comme disent de la santé mes cartes de
tourisme de ce point de vue là mais
c'est l'anticipation d'un possible effet
d'éviction qui viendrait renforcer les
pénuries en France
de notre pays reste primordial car il
n'est pas exclu et c'est un euphémisme
que les laboratoires effectuent leur
choix en fonction des conditions
économiques d'un marché en dépit de tout
évaluation des besoins réels à contrario
le prix des médicaments innovants
atteint lui des sommets certaines
thérapies dépassent les deux millions
d'euros je ne rentrerai pas dans ces
considérations éthiques de construction
du prix d'une thérapie de l'innovation
et donc de celui d'une vie le Conseil
consultatif national d'éthique a
brillamment abordé le sujet en soulevant
les questions les dilemmes et la nature
des arbitrages dans un avis de grande
sagesse c'est la vie 101 intitulée santé
éthique et argent qui se terminent ainsi
par ses mots inspirants la question
éthique posée par l'examen de la
dimension économique du soin explorent
la tension entre l’autonomie et la
solidarité entre la liberté individuelle
et le bien public cette tension ne peut
recevoir de réponse que dans la
recherche d'équité c'est-à-dire dans la
justice
c'est la même recherche d'équilibre
entre des réalités et des ambitions
chacune légitime chacune bienvenue qui
doit guider l'action publique dans
l'identification des solutions afin de
continuer à anticiper et à mieux
anticiper les pénuries nationales et
européennes que nous connaissons et
celles à venir je vous remercie de votre
attention je suis évidemment disponible
pour vos questions
merci beaucoup pour ces longs profonds
liminaires qui ont abordé tous les
sujets je vais directement passer la
parole à Madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur pour une première salle de
questions merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre propos liminaire donc je vais
un peu suivre d'ailleurs la trame de
votre propos puisque vous êtes parti à
juste titre de la feuille de route de
2019 à 2022
et effectivement cette feuille de route
avait fait de la transparence et de
l'exhaustivité de l'information sur les
ruptures d'approvisionnement un des axes
majeurs de la politique du gouvernement
vous l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé mais
cette ambition apparaît
assez inachevée la plupart des personnes
que nous avons auditionné regrettent en
fait on regrettait devant notre
commission d'enquête un manque
d'informations et je pense plus
particulièrement au médecin un décalage
entre l'information que peuvent avoir
les pharmaciens et d'ailleurs vous avez
parlé du logiciel des perructures et les
médecins nous ont dit qu'en fait ils
étaient informés alerté par les par les
pharmaciens mais que eux disposaient de
peu d'informations en tout cas j'allais
dire pas comme en étant en première
ligne alors quels sont à votre avis les
points de blocage pourquoi est-ce que il
en est ainsi est-ce qu'il y a pas des
mesures simples et rapides à apprendre
pour modifier cet état cet état de fait
vous parlez en deuxième deuxième élément
de de la crise du covid qui a accéléré
l'ambition de la feuille de route et a
juste titre je partage vous rendez
hommage au réseau hospitalier et à la
GEPS et justement nous avons auditionné
la geppe ce qui a fait comme vous l'avez
dit un travail absolument remarquable
pendant la période notamment de la crise
et quand nous l'avons nous avons
interrogé donc la GEPS en fait qu'ils
ont pu faire et produire pendant la
crise ils ne peuvent pas la faire hors
de période de crise car en fait les
règlements ne le permettent pas et en
plus vous le savez très bien monsieur le
ministre la GEF n'a pas vocation d'être
en concurrence il y a un certain nombre
d'articles que je vous rappellerai pas
mais que vous connaissez qui qui le
stipule et troisième élément de blocage
si je puis dire que actuellement ils ont
un effectif qui est assez assez faible
au vu des missions qu'ils ont c'est à
peu près 120
ETP et là ils vont se séparer de 40 à 50
TP ce qui va les priver de possibilités
de production etc or c'est dommage c'est
un outil qui peut être extrêmement
intéressant et est-ce que on ne pourrait
pas justement s'appuyer sur la GEPS en
leur donnant les moyens pour avoir
sur des produits pas seulement les
produits qui sont
médicalement d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeur mais sur une liste vraiment
critique est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
avoir justement quand je dis critique ça
veut dire restreinte si vous voulez et
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas envisager
contenu de ces pénuries et vous nous
lavez rappelé qui malheureusement
peuvent encore augmenter ou en tout cas
s'étendre à d'autres
à d'autres produits est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas envisager pour cette
cinquantaine de produits critiques
d'avoir une production publique qui nous
permettrait de retrouver notre
souveraineté ça c'était ma deuxième
deuxième question là la troisième
question c'est concernant la le manque
de gouvernance de l'ensemble du système
qui a souvent été mis en avant et
d'ailleurs dans votre ouvrage vous cite
vous dites il y a une nuit de sigle qui
traduit la complexité et la densité des
agences et structures françaises dans le
champ de la santé alors à la lumière de
vos deux années au ministère de la Santé
est-ce qu'il vous paraît que une réforme
de la gouvernance est souhaitable vous
voyez je vous cite
l'autre question que je veux vous poser
c'est dans la politique on a vu que le
médicament en fait était une variable
d'ajustement au niveau de l'ONDAM hélas
et que autrement dit les contraintes
budgétaires qui sont imposées au secteur
sont extrêmement fortes et elles ne sont
pas compatibles avec une sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement en médicaments
vous savez ma position par rapport à la
dame donc c'est pas de ça donc je me
débattre mais je veux regretter et avoir
votre votre point de vue là dessus sur
le fait que dans cette enveloppe on dame
et bien le médicament est vraiment le
parent pauvre j'ai dit la variable
d'ajustement
mon autre question c'est que vous avez
souligné la politique de relocalisation
de la production de certains principes
actifs essentiels et effectivement vous
êtes l'élu d'un département qui est
fortement marquée par par l'industrie
chimique et nous avons pu avec madame la
Présidente aller visiter le site de
l'usine future du paracétamol que ces 15
relocalisent et d'ailleurs nous avons
visité une zone qui regroupe vous le
savez plusieurs sites ce vaisseau c'est
une plateforme qui est extrêmement
intéressante qui fédère vraiment
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses qui leur
permettent d'avoir une production
sécurisée on va dire donc comment la
France peut encore disons favoriser de
telles relocalisation parce que c'est
une expérience qui est intéressante
c'est bien mais en même temps
il faut peut-être multiplier les choses
mon propos ne vous méprenez pas c'est
pas de dire qu'il faut tout relocaliser
en France ce serait complètement stupide
je pense qu'il faut une coordination et
vous l'avez souligné au niveau européen
et qu'il faut relocaliser au niveau
européen dans une parfaite harmonie
entre les différents les différents pays
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2022 que vous avez
porté il y avait
prévu d'ajouter un nouveau critère de
tarification du médicament tenant à
l'implantation industrielle justement
c'est pour ça que je fais les liens avec
ces 15 etc le sept que nous avons
auditionné nous indiquer que son
utilisation pourrait se limiter aux
médicaments innovants et
de mon point de vue si on ne vise pas
prioritairement les médicaments matures
qui représentent l'essentiel des
pénuries est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
monsieur le ministre que nous manquons
la cible en tout cas que cette mesure va
manquer sa cible et qu'il faudrait ne
pas se limiter à seulement ces
médicaments enfin ma dernière question
c'est concernant les prix des des
médicaments
il nous est apparu en tout cas dans les
dans les dans toutes les auditions que
nous avons pu avoir qui ressortaient en
fait on va dire quatre d'abord le besoin
de transparence de ces prix parce que
nous avons été extrêmement au départ
surprise et surpris mais du fait que
personne n'était bien au fait de ce que
faisait le sexe et qu'est-ce qui le CEPS
pardon et ce que faisait qu'est-ce qui
constituait le prix qu'elles étaient les
critères etc mais ce qui ressort c'est
en fait d'avoir une vraie transparence
sur le prix et que soit vraiment dans
cette transparence pris en compte le
coût de production réelle
le respect des normes environnementales
et le respect aussi des conditions de
travail donc d'énormes on va dire
sociales pour aller vite parce que si
les il y a eu des localisations en Chine
et en Asie là encore vous l'avez
souligné c'était par rapport
aux normes environnementales qui étaient
vraiment moins exigeante je veux dire et
puis y compris les conditions salariales
etc donc deuxième le respect le service
évidemment médical rendu je vois
peut-être dû lui dire en premier c'est
pas hiérarchiser et enfin le bénéfice
normal entre guillemets normal ou
éthique ou reconnu par tous évidemment
pour produire ce prix et si on a cette
transparence au niveau du prix du du
médicament il y aura quand même une vue
d'ensemble qui permettra à chacun et à
chacune d'avoir un positionnement et y
compris d'ailleurs de redonner confiance
il me semble aux patientes et aux
patient s voilà les questions qui me
viennent à l'esprit après vous avoir
entendu et je vous remercie d'avance de
vos réponses
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
c'est noté cette question madame la
rapporteur d'abord sur le décalage
d'information entre les médecins et le
pharmacien sur les ruptures alors
aujourd'hui les ruptures sont tout
inscrites sur le site de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut aller
chercher l'information et on a eu
effectivement le des retours comme quoi
c'était pas très simple de s'y connecter
et donc l'idée est peut-être
effectivement de revoir cela je crois
qu'il y a une mission qui est en cours
en tout cas un travail qui est en cours
pour vendre des choses plus
intelligibles après si je prends ma
casquette de médecin je recevais de
temps en temps des mails sur ma boîte
hospitalière m'informant que des
médicaments qui étaient relatifs à ma
discipline allait être en pénurie mais
parfois c'est vrai que je prescrivais
des médicaments à des patients qui me
rappelaient en me disant c'est sympa
docteur mais enfin personne n'en a donc
c'est assez pénible et je sais et là je
me mets à la place du médecin on ne
comprend pas pourquoi est-ce que tel
médicament n'est plus disponible alors
que c'est un médicament qu'on avait
l'habitude d'utiliser c'est un peu
rajean donc il faut sans doute rendre
l'information plus intelligible je
prends votre point en tout cas je le
transmets
deuxième question sur la loi prévoit que
la production oui vous parlez de la GEPS
sur la dans les faits il y a un
texte qui est en préparation
là-dessus
il y a une nouvelle feuille de route en
réalité qui est en préparation elle
devra tirer les conclusions de ce qui
s'est passé pendant la crise moi je suis
sensible je trouve pertinente si vous me
permettez de les caractériser les pistes
que vous dessinez au ministre de la
Santé de de dans décider
au quotidien c'est pas le rôle de la
c'est évidemment mais c'est parce que
vous dites de produire des médicaments
d'usage courant pour toute la population
parce que là il sait pas c'est pas 120
ou plus ou moins 40 qu'il faudrait c'est
évidemment sans ou 200 fois plus de
salariés vous faites allusion à ce qui
pourrait ressembler à l'idée du pôle
public du médicament à travers votre de
votre question
plus restreint pour la production
publique en tout cas de médicaments
faut pas écarter cette possibilité j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de la crise avec le
sisa tractium qui a montré que c'était
possible j'ai connaissance du fait qu'il
y a des tensions autour de
l'amoxicilline pendant les que pour les
tensions autour de la boxicilline il y a
eu des préparations magistrates et
hospitalières qui ont été largement
utilisés à nouveau là c'est au ministre
de ce prononcer sur sur ces questions
réforme de la gouvernance en santé alors
là vous ouvrez quelque chose qui me
semble-t-il beaucoup plus large que que
la question médicament qui nous
occupe on pourrait parler de savoir si
le parachèvement de la loi de rosier le
Bachelot vous avez auditionné passe ou
non par la création d'une Agence
nationale etc enfin voilà c'est là on
est dans quelque chose qui qui est
extrêmement grand mais je pense qu'on
peut faire effectivement une
simplification du paysage et différentes
agences sanitaires mais c'est pas mon
rôle que de que de que dire que de dire
laquelle
le médicament pour la régulation de la
dame je l'ai dit en introduction il y a
une mission qui est en cours donnée
lancée par la première ministre les
conclusions
vous appelez à plus de relocalisation
pardon
mais je sais mais je parle de mon
expérience personnelle je n'ai pas
d'expérience je n'ai pas encore eu la
chance d'être sénateur si jamais ça
arrivait un jour je me ferai ma propre
idée
et je sais que le Sénat est capable
d'avoir des
affranchir des clivages partisans que la
traditionnel sur la relocalisation vous
donnez le chiffre qui je crois est
factuel de plus d'un bilan qui est de
plus de sang en deux ans c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu 200 usines de plus qui ont
ouvertes qui il y a eu d'usine qui ont
fermé en deux ans dans notre pays je
parle pas la queue du médicament mais ce
qui a déjà contraste avec des années
pour ne pas dire des décennies de
désindustrialisation et Marx il était
besoin de le marquer
que la volonté du Président de la
République de retrouver la souveraineté
française et européenne en matière
productive et industrielle commence à
porter ses fruits et donc parmi ses
usines il y a des usines qui seront
amenées à fabriquer des médicaments je
voulais dire mon sens c'est plutôt un
sujet européen qu'un sujet français il
faut qu'on puisse se répartir et pour ça
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une coopération
une coordonnation coordination
européenne assez assez précoce vous
parlez de
mettre en place un critère de production
en France dans le prix de tous les
médicaments alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
l'avait fait pour les médicaments
innovants je sais plus si le texte se
limitait au sol médicament innovant ou
non
oui c'est l'article 65 de la FS 2022
dont vous parlez je peux pas dans mes
fonctions actuelles tirer le bilan la
mission sur la régulation s'y intéresse
chers unique cet article c'est déjà une
avancée parce que nombreux sont celles
et ceux qui demandaient de prendre en
compte la dimension industrielle dans la
fixation du prix et on est allé on a
adopté quelque chose qui était qui est
sans doute plus plus précis plus précis
que cela et sur le besoin de
transparence dans les prix
alors il y a la notion de secret des
affaires et de secret de l'industriel
qui fait que il y a des choses dont nous
n'avons pas à connaître publiquement ça
je crois que il y a eu plusieurs fois ce
débat dans les différents hémicycles et
à chaque fois c'était cet argument mais
qui me paraît tout à fait valable
il y a eu beaucoup de grands projets de
grands soirs de la grande réforme de
l'élaboration de la manière de trouver
le prix d'un médicament je crois qu'il y
avait même littr c'était l'index
thérapeutique relatif qui devait
permettre de fusionner le SMS et la SMR
tous ces sites qu'on adore dans les
politiques publiques et en santé en
particulier pour avoir un espèce
d'indicateur composite qui tiendrait
compte de l'ensemble des coûts de
production de transport d'innovation et
en fait ça n'a jamais vraiment vu le
jour parce qu'à chaque fois ça se
heurter à la complexité d'un marché
mondialisé mais sans doute qu'on peut
faire mieux dans la façon de déterminer
le prix d'un médicament je sais que
parfois c'est des grandes batailles et
quand vous êtes ministre de la santé
c'est parfois des choix qui vous faut
faire qui peuvent être compliqués et
parfois source de grande fiertés
sont-ils c'était lorsque
j'étais ministre et que nous avons
autorisé le remboursement du castria
dans la mucoviscidose un médicament qui
parce qu'il était cher était bloqué non
pas en France mais dans la plupart des
pays du monde et la France a finalement
été l'un des premiers à autoriser la
mission le marché de ce médicament même
si son coup était élevé quand on voit il
m'a été j'ai eu le bonheur de voir des
des jeunes atteints de buthoviscidose et
dont l'état de santé c'est fortement
amélioré depuis là on peut se dire que
c'est quelque chose qui nécessite
vraiment qu'on y mette le prix parfois
c'est plus compliqué parce qu'on se
heurte le sentiment qu'on peut avoir et
le sentiment n'est jamais très bon dans
un monde de d'évidence base médecine
mais les retours que peuvent faire des
malades de l'utilisation d'un traitement
qui n'est pas forcément remboursé parce
que le prix n'est pas suffisamment élevé
au regard de ce qu'on attend le
laboratoire qui dispose un monopole et
du brevet et qui nous dit qu'il est
commercialisera pas si on donne pas le
bon prix nous donne envie de pousser un
peu de pousser un peu la porte et de
forcer des verrous à contrario des fois
c'est vrai qu'on autorise des
médicaments qui vont être très chers qui
sont parfois des deuxièmes des 3e ligne
de chimio dans des maladies
qui dont l'espérance d'amélioration de
la santé peut-être peut se poser en
termes de questions
on est tous vous avez tous les pays
occidentaux sur soumis à cette même
nécessité de mettre en place de mettre
donner accès plutôt possible à
innovation au prix le meilleur possible
en étant jamais pieds liés par les
laboratoires ça c'est absolument
impensable et impossible et donc c'est
le rôle du CEPS il a pas un rôle facile
il est pas doté d'énormément de moyens
pour le faire mais de gens qui sont très
compétents et donc on essaye PLFSS après
PLFSS d'améliorer leurs conditions de
travail et d'exercices de leurs missions
c'est pas toujours simple il faut
pouvoir se dire les choses
merci beaucoup je vais passer aux
questions et pour information on me dit
qu'il n'y a plus de délégué
interministériel à antibiorésistance il
y en avait un quand j'étais en place il
y en a plus mais c'est désormais une
mission intégrée au sein de la Direction
générale de la santé donc je
ique
de certains médicaments en cas de
rupture c'est fait au cas par cas ça a
été fait par exemple pour certains
vaccins comme le vaccin en banque kpops
après évaluation de la stabilité du
vaccin par la NSM voilà
après ça reste une solution
transitoire mais qui peut avoir son
utilité en tout cas aux États-Unis de la
mise en place donc Bruno Belin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour votre intervention
on a bien commencé la journée avec
Madame Bachelot et on l'a fini bien avec
vous entre temps
la qualité des propos n'a pas toujours
été égal mais ça me permet de réagir et
pardon si ça sort du cadre pour lequel
vous êtes
auditionné mais le pharmacien d'officine
que je suis toujours en activité tient à
saluer la façon dont notre pays a géré
la crise la pandémie qui a quand même
conduit un moment donné à un nombre de
décès
inimaginé
un Airbus par jour un Titanic tous les
huit jours c'est ce à quoi nous avons
été confrontés dans les différentes
vagues que vous connaissez évidemment
mieux que quiconque et donc à mon avis
faut dire voilà chapeau merci même si on
peut toujours tout est perfectible je
crois qu'on peut être fier de ce qui a
été fait grâce à l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé dans ce pays
mais il faut j'en suis convaincu si on
veut donner un avenir aux médicaments et
à la façon dont on peut soigner
sacraliser et sauver la pharmacie
française
il y a de mauvaises idées et je me
permets effectivement de le dire la
délivrance à l'unité en est une je l'ai
tenté j'ai expérimenté alors je vous
passe le fait de un peu des passions
perdus désorientés qui sont habitués à
la boîte orange parce qu'on met dans un
sac plastique et qui n'ont plus la même
boîte depuis toujours etc je vous passe
sous les contraintes administratives du
numéro de lot de la sérialisation je
sais maintenant on fait un petit QR code
sur toutes les boîtes pour la
traçabilité et puis parce que ça évite
paraît-il ça existait des des
spécialités qui sortaient qui revenaient
en officine et qui ressortait de cette
on l'a essayé aussi sur la préparation
parce qu'il a fallu faire aussi des
préparations d'amoxicilline on est passé
par là on a visité la Commission s'est
rendu d'ailleurs chez Delpech et on a
tous certains
volontaires pour faire ce type de
préparation ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
on va en arriver à la question du prix
parce que si on doit mettre le prix réel
aussi du médicament France pour
permettre aux répartiteurs de vivre
rappelez-vous avant la MDL la marge
dégressive lycée il y avait un
pourcentage pour les maintenant vous
étiez pas encore en exercice mais on a
connu ça pour les plus anciens d'entre
nous
on vous a raconté l'histoire il y avait
un pourcentage pour répartiteur un
rapporteur un pourcentage pour la
recherche un pourcentage pour le
remettre etc et ça arrivait à stabiliser
depuis que si on bouge le prix du
médicament on va avoir peut-être
effectivement un retour à ça mais on va
voir un prix excessif en pharmacie qui
n'arriveront plus à se revendre
quand je dis il faut sacraliser la
pharmacie c'est aussi aujourd'hui qui
est à peu près 10% 8 à 10% des licences
qui ont disparu en France vous le savez
comme moi ça a des conséquences d'accès
à la santé ça des conséquences sur
l'aménagement du territoire parce que ce
sont les plus petites officines et les
plus petites dans les territoires les
plus ruraux qui ont aussi disparu ce qui
est un vrai sujet vous le savez qui
manque aujourd'hui à peu près un millier
de postes en officine et on estime qu'il
va manquer 6 à 7000 pharmaciens d'ici la
fin de la décennie
vous êtes un membre éminent le
gouvernement donc ça fait partie des
messages sur lesquels vous êtes crédible
et que vous devez relayer on est en
train de créer les déserts
pharmaceutiques après avoir créé les
déserts médicaux rappelez-vous de ce
qu'on se dit aujourd'hui ce que je
crains malheureusement que nous sommes
certains exercices encore aujourd'hui
dans cette salle à le voir avant la fin
de la décennie donc il faut arriver à
faire confiance un peu plus aux
pharmaciens sur la délivrance
on passe beaucoup de temps on a passé
tous beaucoup de temps l'activité a été
chronophage et destructrice et donc je
crois que il faut permettre aux
officinaux de travailler dans les
meilleures conditions et je peux vous
assurer que la délivrance à l'unité
aujourd'hui n'est pas envisageable
très bien Laurence Harris
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre moi je j'aimerais
revenir sur sur la question de
sur la question de du prix j'ai pas
votre expertise ni l'expertise de mon
collègue donc j'essaye de comprendre les
choses et d'avancer sachant que
on est loin du yakafaucon et plus on
creuse plus on se rend compte que les
choses sont pas simples vous avez dit à
mon avis de manière très honnête dans
votre propos liminaire on a à la fois
des prix très bas d'un certain nombre de
médicaments de tous les jours et puis
des médicaments qui sont très très chers
et ça va plus loin c'est à dire qu'en
fait cette fragmentation de de des prix
et bien elle s'est traduite aussi par
une fragmentation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et on voit bien quand on
regarde un peu la cartographie des
acteurs de l'industrie pharmaceutique
qu'on a des PME PMI qui tirent la langue
qui sont en difficulté qui et puis des
grands labos quand même qui ont une
stratégie
internationale
multinationale et qui sont dans d'autres
faire alors vous dites que la réponse ne
peut être que européenne moi je vous
suis allègrement là-dessus et on
travaille beaucoup avec Pascal grunis
quand vous parliez de d'être capable de
sortir des clivages dans le cadre de la
commission des affaires européennes on
travaille beaucoup là-dessus mais on se
rend compte aussi que au niveau européen
on est un peu
en difficulté parce que d'une part la
santé est une compétence des États et
c'est qu'une compétence complémentaire
au niveau européen mais par contre la
libre circulation est une compétence
européenne et on a vrai du marché unique
et là on a vraiment l'impression qu'on
est qu'on est un peu pris entre deux
trois feux et que finalement on se fait
un peu
on se met en position de faiblesse par
rapport aux acteurs de du secteur et que
on s'en sort pas en fait moi j'aimerais
que vous nous disiez peu par
l'expérience que vous avez eue
comment vous avez vécu ces espèces de
d'injonction contradictoires parce que
comme vous le dites très très justement
on peut pas quel est quel est le
gouvernance qui se qui s'interdit de
donner accès
à un médicament innovant quitte à ce que
ce soit très cher parce que je veux dire
quelque soit d'où on vient on a envie de
soigner et que c'est une c'est une c'est
une responsabilité qu'on a mais en même
temps ben on se met quelque part en
situation de de d'être
pris au piège de du prix et de du manque
de transparence comme le soulignait à la
fois la présidente et la rapporteur tout
à l'heure donc moi
deux questions la question de savoir
est-ce que quelque part on
ne faut pas tout changer parce que et ce
qui vient d'être dit sur les pharmacies
est assez révélateur c'est-à-dire qu'on
plus on avance moi c'est ce que
j'appelle la théorie des sables mouvants
c'est à dire que on prend une décision
et on s'enfonce et que toute décision
que moi on s'enfonce encore et qu'il
faudrait tout balayer tout remettre sur
le sur le tapis y compris notre système
de production notre système de
rémunération du médicament notre système
de de financement de la protection
sociale ça c'est la première question et
au niveau européen est-ce qu'il faut
faire bouger les lignes en termes de de
compétences est-ce que vous l'avez vécu
vous comme comme un obstacle dans et que
la pénurie vient aussi de cette
incapacité au niveau européen de trouver
des solutions même si ce qui a été fait
est remarquable a été remarquable dans
la gestion de crise mais c'est pendant
la gestion de crise et la réponse que
vous enfin la remarque a fait leur
rapporteur tout à l'heure sur sur la
GEPS et très révélatrice et est-ce qu'il
faut pas
aller vers un modèle qu'on a eu pendant
la crise de manière plus normalisée
excusez-moi c'est peut-être un peu con
emiliane pomirol
oui merci madame la Présidente je vais
être plus brève parce que
ma collègue Laurence arrivée on me dit
j'allais dire les 90% de ce que je
voulais dire ça va me permettre
un peu plus brève juste vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre combien vous avez
une phrase qui m'a fait plaisir puisque
vous dites que vous n'écartez pas la
possibilité d'une production publique
qui pourrait être un aimant de réponse
en tout cas pour certains médicaments
critiques effectivement je crois que
c'est une voix que nous aimerions voir
explorer je vais pas revenir sur les
diminutions d'effectif de la geppse sur
mais cette possibilité de production
publique je crois qu'il faut pas
l'écarter de
d'un revers de main et que il faut qu'on
y travaille tous et je voudrais revenir
moi aussi sur sur la transparence vous
avez vous aussi
invoqué un argument qu'on nous oppose
sans arrêt qui est celui du secret des
affaires
et le CPS se réfugie derrière le secret
des affaires et c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui est un peu compliqué
et admettre en tout cas pour nous parce
que le médicament n'est pas une marche
en dise je vous ai interpellé d'ailleurs
sur la marchandisation de la santé et je
trouve que la dérive est de plus en plus
grande dans ce domaine là le médicament
n'est pas une marchandise puisqu'il est
remboursé par la Sécurité Sociale et que
donc c'est de l'argent public qu'une
deuxième fois vient
faire vivre j'allais dire les
industriels or le flou qui existe sur ce
secret des affaires permet je le crois
aujourd'hui à des Big Pharma parce que
c'est effectivement il y a les il y a
les deux volets Laurence Lady il y a les
petites PME dans qui font les
médicaments matures et puis il y a les
Big Pharma qui aujourd'hui se concentre
uniquement sur les thérapies géniques ou
les biotech et abandonnent il y en a eu
Sanofi à l'audition déjà il y a un an et
demi qui nous l'a confirmé abandonne
quasiment la R&D en matière chimique
parce que effectivement une boîte de
doliprane ou une boîte de Velox ça
rapporte pas autant qu'une thérapie
génique en 2 millions d'euros alors
Monsieur ministre est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire comment on peut
justifier un tel prix et quelle est
l'action qu'on pourrait avoir le
gouvernement en matière de contrôle et
en tout cas ou de d'indication pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de prix pareil vous
avez cité l'exemple de certains
traitements mais on sait bien que le
prix pour l'hépatite C par exemple n'a
pas été le même en France il a été en
Inde donc c'est pas le prix de
production qui compte ni le transport
etc c'est selon la capacité du pays à
payer à accepter un paiement donc est-ce
qu'on peut pas avoir en matière
législative quelque chose à faire dans
ce domaine là
il reste encore deux deux collègues qui
en ont des paroles Laurence Meyer Braun
merci madame le Président Monsieur
administré mon ma question elle est
aussi comme les collègues qui se sont
exprimés avant moi autour du prix parce
que
vous l'avez évoqué
le secret des affaires pourtant là on le
sent dans toute la population on
comprend bien qu'on efface à des
montants extrêmement importants et que
c'est de l'argent public les entreprises
du Big Pharma ont quitté nos pays pour
avoir un une rentabilité plus importante
en Chine en Inde ou ailleurs donc on
licencié c'est bien l'argent public qui
a pris tout ce monde-là en charge
ensuite on verse des crédits pour
recherche je vois Sanofi qui a touché 7
milliards d'euros de crédit pour
recherche en disant et et par le même
temps elle licencie 5000 chercheurs et
puis aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit on
essaye de relocaliser mais on paye
encore ces entreprises là pour
relocaliser or ça devient tellement gros
que on peut se poser des questions de du
prix réel et on l'a évoqué on a eu un
laboratoire juste avant vous qui nous a
dit c'est le premier qui nous disent ils
sont pris réel qui est très bas on a vu
aussi sur le vaccin quand on entend en
Europe la vente du vaccin à 120 euros et
que le coût de production est à moins de
10 euros alors que les marchés sont
énormes pour les états ça devient
difficile de de pouvoir l'accepter le
médicament est n'est pas un bien de
consommation comme les autres vous
l'avez dit mais parce qu'il y a la santé
parce qu'il y a la vie ou la mort
derrière et bien on en profite un peu et
on fait monter la peur l'angoisse on
voit bien sur des sur des des
traitements très très chers des piqûres
à 500.000 euros un million d'euros où on
fait jouer des des associations qui sont
créées par les Big Pharma des
associations de malades et qui vont
venir aussi
faire faire comprendre que l'État doit
payer la force publique elle ne peut pas
être à la botte de de des grands
financiers elle ne peut pas il y a un
moment il faut que ça s'arrête et c'est
ce qu'on attend de vous pendant la crise
covid elles on parle de l'Europe mais au
niveau de l'Europe c'est encore pire
puisqu'on a donné des des millions et
des millions à des laboratoires
européens ou mondiaux qui finalement au
bout non pas produit de vaccins et ont
gardé quand même l'argent public qui
leur a été versé donc il y avait même
pas l'obligation de résultats l'argent a
été versé beaucoup d'argent il n'y a
rien au bout et c'est bon ben on dit
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps qu'on a pas pu
etc et on parle aujourd'hui de l'OMS qui
va quand même avoir aussi un pouvoir sur
les réglementations de santé et la
circulation des habitants du monde pour
la santé donc est-ce que c'est plus
facile on comprend bien que l'Europe à
son mot à dire mais est-ce que c'est
plus facile ça veut dire aussi
certainement encore des budgets plus
importants de dépenser des budgets
publics
merci Corinne Imbert merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
dans l'exercice des fonctions qui
étaient les vôtres en tant que ministre
de la Santé
avez-vous eu connaissance
des parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
exportations parallèles de médicaments
par des grossistes répartiteurs par des
shortlineers puisque les médicaments ne
revient au prix seraient achetés à un
prix meilleur dans d'autres pays qu'on
peut des pays européens aviez-vous
connaissance de ce shortliner de ces
grossistes répartiteurs qui
avaient ces pratiques et
avez-vous le nom de ces short liner
c'est grossiste répartiteur puisque
c'est quelque chose qui revient
régulièrement qui est dénoncé mais
avez-vous connaissance précisément de
ces de ces opérateurs qui interviennent
dans la chaîne logistique de
l'approvisionnement médicament
et qui aurait profité de prix bas en
France pour vendre un meilleur prix dans
d'autres pays je vous remercie
je vais vous laisser répondre cette
série de questions et puis après j'aurai
quelques questions et nos concurrons
avec la rapporteur
on dit parfois
que les Français peuvent avoir le
sentiment que les politiques publiques
n'arrivent pas
à répondre à des objectifs ou à des
enjeux qui peuvent être parfois des
oranges du quotidien ou parfois des
logiques de bon sens
quand les Français sont très nombreux à
vous dire qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on continue de leur
vendre une boîte de médicaments pour 11
jours alors qu'ils ont 6 jours de
traitement quand ils ouvrent leur
pharmacie familiale en rentrant à la
maison et qu'ils ont ils se foutent ces
petites pharmacies que vous ouvrez et
vous avez des boîtes qui vous tombent
dessus tellement vous en avez et que de
temps en temps dans le grand ménage de
printemps vous regardez les dates de
péremption là ça fait trois ans qu'il
est plus là on a tous ça chez nous
franchement on a tous ça on a tous ça
chez moi j'ouvre un tiroir dans la salle
de bain je tombe sur une boîte de
médicaments d'un truc qui m'a été
prescrit on a tous ça et on se dit alors
ça fait du carton du plastique avec des
blisters et des médicaments je sais pas
quoi en faire je les garde je les jette
il y a des recyclages qui existent et
j'invite les Français qui nous regardent
nombreux à aller recycler les boîtes de
médicaments il n'empêche que je n'ai
plus le chiffre en tête pardonnez-moi ça
fait des années mais le nombre de tonnes
de produits actifs de médicaments qu'on
bazarde ou qu'on stock dans les
pharmacies je comprends parfaitement la
demande des français qu'on évolue vers
une dispensation à l'unité
il y a un certain pays dans lesquels
vous allez et quand vous avez le malheur
d'être malade on vous donne une
ordonnance et vous repartez avec une
petite boîte plastique que vous pouvez
d'ailleurs recycler aussi avec le nombre
de comprimés dont vous avez besoin moi
je me dis qu'il y a pas sur le papier de
raison de penser que l'Europe serait pas
capable de faire ce que les États-Unis
font basiquement et c'est vrai que ayant
dit cela et ben on est heurté à des
normes de sérialisation de de
traçabilité qui sont sans doute
fondamentales pourquoi je vous pourquoi
je vous dis ça avec sincérité comme ça
c'est parce que en fait ça je l'ai
trouvé sur ma route tout le temps dès
que je voulais mener des politiques
publiques de santé alors faisant face à
une crise sanitaire qui qui nécessitait
de prendre des mesures extraordinaires
j'ai pu prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions dites extraordinaires des
temps courts
ça vous paraît peut-être mais sur le
papier permettre aux pharmacies de se
payer aux pharmacies d'officine de
produire leur propre gel hydroalcoolique
il a fallu quand même un arrêté je crois
ou un décret pour l'autoriser
les pharmaciens pardon ils ont fait
combien d'années d'études
ils ont un diplôme ils ont fait de la
chimie organique qui connaissent
parfaitement la pharmacopée ils sont en
contact des Français ils sont quand même
21000 dans le pays ils sont partout ils
demandent d'avoir une place plus
importante dans ce pays dans l'offre de
soins il a fallu quand même prendre un
arrêté dérogatoire exceptionnel pour
leur permettre de produire du gel
hydroalcoolique
je vous le dis comme ça la télémédecine
pardon je sors du médicament mais quand
j'arrive en fait 10000 acte de
téléconsultation par semaine dans notre
pays dix mille c'est risible parce que
les règles qui encadraient souvent la
demande des professionnels et des
corporatismes qui ont voulu revenir par
la fenêtre une fois que la porte de la
crise sanitaire c'était fermé mais il
fallait être en contact d'un être en
présence d'un soignant avoir déjà vu une
première fois le médecin qu'on allait
consulter par télémédecine le tout avec
un logiciel moi j'ai pris un arrêté j'ai
dit ce sera Skype WhatsApp FaceTime peu
importe on a déjà vu le médecin ou non
et on n'a pas besoin d'avoir une
infirmière à côté pour parler à son
médecin et on est passé à un million
d'actes de télémédecine par semaine donc
la question c'est est-ce que parfois il
faut forcer la porte et que ça permet
d'améliorer l'état de santé de la
population la réponse elle est oui et ma
conviction elle est forte maintenant une
fois ayant dit cela j'ai pas non plus la
période s'y prêtait pas mais sur la
dispensation à l'unité du médicament on
m'a toujours dit que c'était très
compliqué alors si à chaque fois qu'on
m'avait dit c'est très compliqué j'avais
dit tant pis on le fait pas je vous
garantis qu'on aurait peut-être pas
passer la même crise donc je pense qu'il
faudra à être reposé se repencher sur
les voies et moyens d'avancer sur cette
question de dispensation limitée par
ailleurs sur le rôle du pharmacien moi
je remercie les pharmaciens qui ont été
des acteurs absolument magistraux de la
crise sanitaire depuis le 1er jour mais
vraiment je remercie de l'Ordre des
pharmaciens aussi qui a été un
catalyseur de la mobilisation de tous
ces acteurs contreparties ils ont pu
avoir une augmentation
conséquente du nombre de vaccins qui
peuvent faire ça aussi on pourrait se
poser la question en fait pardon je vais
me faire taper sur les doigts mais ce
qu'il faut vraiment saisir la Haute
Autorité de santé à chaque fois qu'il
faut se poser la question de savoir si
quelqu'un qui a fait au moins 6 ans
d'études de santé peu ou non faire un
vaccin ou renouveller un vaccin en
fonction de l'âge du patient et la
couleur du de la casquette du capitaine
je pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup plus
simple dans notre pays et en fait je
pense que qu'on le veuille ou non on a
plus le choix parce qu'on fait face à
des désert médicaux et que vous et moi
quand on se déplace sur nos territoires
respectifs le premier truc dont nous
parle tout le monde c'est on veut
pouvoir se faire soigner et on a peur de
plus pouvoir y arriver voir on y arrive
plus donc il faut encore une fois forcer
tous les verrous et être capable
d'innover de se dire qu'il y a des
règles qui doivent sauter parce que ce
sont des normes qui ne s'entendent pas
quand encore moins quand on manque comme
ça de professionnels de santé voilà j'ai
dit mon mot politique sur la question
sur le le
que vous dire d'autre alors vous les
mets beaucoup de choses il faut que je
vous en dise beaucoup et en même temps
j'ai pas envie d'être trop long je crois
avoir répondu au sanitaire Belin sur
l'évolution du marché ah oui après sur
la question du prix il y a eu
l'évolution majeure du marché du
médicament pendant très longtemps les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques étaient
rentables à partir de ce qu'on appelait
les blockbusters qui étaient les
médicaments d'usage tellement courant
qu'on en vendait des milliers des
millions de boîtes à tout le monde qui
était parfois des innovations de rupture
quand les statines sont arrivées dans
les maladies vasculaires par exemple ça
a été une innovation de rupture et donc
ça a été des médicaments qui ont été
payés à un prix assez élevé parce que
c'est une innovation et que moi ça me
choque pas qu'on paye l'innovation dès
lors que le laboratoire réinvestit dans
la recherche et développement et puis
ensuite ces stat elles ont été
génériques la règle du générique c'est
une règle formidable c'est quand même ce
qui permet de faire chuter des prix pour
des médicaments qui ont épuisé leur
période de forte rentabilité et là on a
ce moment-là les prix des génériques qui
qui permettent de faire chuter tout ça
et puis du coup bah les laboratoires ils
ont perdu entre guillemets ce marché des
blockbusters parce qu'on en a pas
vraiment développé de nouveau depuis les
aspirines les statines des antibiaux et
donc le marché s'est réorienté et ça
tombe bien parce que l'évolution de la
recherche nous a permis d'entrevoir ce
qu'on appelle la médecine des 4 p alors
j'en souviens toujours de deux de tête
c'est préventive et personnalisés il y
en a deux autres
c'est à dire une médecine individuelle
le bon médicament au bon patient au bon
moment alors là ils ont cherché leur
modèle de financement ils le cherchent
toujours parce que c'est l'innovation
c'est pas un truc que vous avez
distribué par 50 millions de boîtes aux
Français mais c'est le médicament vous
allez donner à Monsieur ou à Madame et
dont il va falloir à chaque fois adopter
adopter les dosages etc il y a eu plein
de modèles de réflexion pour le
financement certains pensaient que les
test compagnon était la bonne manière de
procéder d'autres ont dit faut
fonctionner à la rentabilité à
l'efficacité du médicament moi j'étais
plutôt enclin à trouver que payer un
médicament en fonction de son efficacité
ce n’est pas mal puis en 2018 je crois
il y a le sol le sovaldi qui arrive je
sais plus qui en a parlé ici le
médicament contre l'hépatite C
commercialisé par jade à l'époque
c'était avant c'était dans le mandat
d'avant alors pardon c'était mon mandat
d'avant c'était 2014 pardon alors
j'étais pas rapporté en général encore
excusez-moi mais lui le médicament
arrive super nouvelle
super nouvelle on va guérir des gens
qu'on hépatite c'est on va on va plus
les greffer
ils vont arrêter de mourir super
nouvelle quand on a vu le prix du
médicament ça fait super nouvelle mais
ça va nous coûter parce que c'est une
question d'arbitrage si vous mettez un
milliard pour soigner l'hépatite C c'est
pas c'est un milliard que vous avez pas
prendre donc ça veut dire que tous les
autres médicaments vont chuter un prix
donc à l'époque l'industrie du
médicament le LEM qu'il est représente
était même en train de dire les amis de
JDA ils abusent un peu parce que le
milliard qui demande pour leur
médicament certes qui est très bien on
va nous le prendre en baisse de prix sur
tous les autres médicaments c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé alors on
avait mis à l'époque un mécanisme dans
la loi qui faisait qu'au-delà d'une
certaine enveloppe on récupérait via une
taxe sur le chiffre d'affaires au
laboratoire je connais l'esprit retors
qui avait développé ce truc là c'était
moi mais mais de manière à éviter de
perdre trop mais j'avais convoqué au
Parlement le patron de GVA de l'époque
qui était venu et je lui avais demandé
de m'expliquer je sais plus combien
c'était 90000 euros par
j'avais demandé la même question que
celle que vous posez combien ça vous a
coûté en recherche d'innovation en
l'occurrence il y avait ils avaient
racheté une petite start-up américaine
et qui avait prévu dans des documents
internes devant le médicament beaucoup
moins cher ils avaient fait une OPA et
ils avaient décidé de faire beaucoup
plus de marge donc à l'époque bon
c'était pas très content et vous étiez
là d'ailleurs avec moi
et donc on a et j'avais demandé à
expliquer moi il m'avait dit mais
regardez combien vous économisez
greffes il y a plus les décès vous
gagnez l'espérance de vie etc donc c'est
de l'argent à moins que vous payez j'ai
dit si on ne raisonne comme ça mettez
dans la catégorie dépense les retraites
qu'on va payer si on raisonne comme ça
donc c'est très compliqué en fait de
trouver il y a pas de martingale et en
fait pourquoi il y a pas eu la grande
réforme du mode du financement du
médicament c'est qu'en fait les jardins
de la français ça existe pas donc en
fonction des catégories médicaments si
vous faites face à un truc très innovant
ou un truc moyennement innovant c'est
une innovation de rupture ou si c'est
juste changer le packaging et mettre une
forme libération prolongée du même
médicament il faut pas traiter les
choses à la même manière et pour ça que
le CEPS il fait ce job là vous parlez de
transparence le prix du médicament il
est public c'est transparent par contre
la manière dont sont négocié les prix
mais pardonnez-moi je veux bien qu'on
fasse une règle différente pour le
médicament que pour tout le reste de
l'industrie mais je trouve que le secret
des affaires ça existe
tout ce qui ne concerne aussi pas le
médicament non mais
je vous dis pas autre chose je vous dis
que j'ai posé mais fait d'armes
peut-être pour moi mais
référez-vous à la presse mais pour moi
j'étais comme vous scandalisé de ne pas
comprendre comment était élaboré le prix
d'un médicament et parfois c'est très
compliqué et alors parfois vous faites
des choix éthiques et encore une fois
quand vous avez un labo qui vous vend un
médicament pour soigner des gamins qu'on
a mis copycidoz et que ça coûte très
cher vous faites ce choix là non mais
dans ce cas-là dans ce cas du coup alors
du coup à quel moment vous ne faites pas
ce choix là je vais vous dire je crois
je crois que de mémoire c'est le
ministre je crois que de mémoire le seul
pays qui avait mis en place un système
alors eux trait à anglo-saxonne c'était
les quali c'est l'Angleterre c'est le
Quality Edge life year adjessman life
year en anglais est formidable
est très sensible en anglais et ils
avaient des c'est-à-dire combien coûte
une année de vie en bonne santé c'est un
quali ou combien coûte
deux ans de vie en ayant 50% de perte de
santé et ils ont donné un prix qu'ils
ont donné un prix à la vie et en disant
tout ce qui dépasse on rembourse pas et
tout ce qui dépasse pas voilà
honnêtement vous voyez faire ça en
France on veut pas moi je veux pas comme
médecin comme comme parlementaire comme
ministre évidemment non donc il faut
continuer de faire de pousser dans les
négociations qui sont très serrées entre
le CEPS et les labos pour faire en sorte
que dans le cas de l'enveloppe qui est
attribuée au labo chacun est conscience
que s'il demande trop et bien c'est les
autres qui vont voir leur prix qui vont
baisser mais on est au début des
problèmes la thérapie génique est une
formidable nouvelle mais ça peut coûter
très cher la médecine des quatre P j'ai
retrouvé les 4P ou plutôt quelqu'un eu
la gentillesse de me l'envoyer c'est
préventif prédictif participatif et
personnalisée ça va coûter très cher et
en fait il va falloir qu'on trouve un
mécanisme de régulation de ce marché ce
marché du médicament parce qu'on va
vouloir payer moi j'ai des patients
enfin des personnes que je connais qui
qui souffrent horriblement de migraines
ou d'Algérie vasculaire de la face et un
médicament qui semble les soulager très
fortement mais dont l'ASMR
tel qu'elle a été produite par la Haute
Autorité de Santé j'ai pas en juger fait
que le médicament ne peut pas être
remboursé au prix qu'il est donc ils
vont chercher leur médicament à
l'étranger ça vaut plus de 300 ou 400
balles par mois et il me dit si je le
prends plus je vis plus voyez où on en
est donc c'est très compliqué ces
arbitrages permanents qu'il faut pouvoir
réaliser c'est c'est à la fois politique
à la fois hautement scientifique
sur le le j'ai un peu disgressé pardon
vous parlez de l'Europe pour moi
l'Europe c'est pas du tout un problème
l'Europe c'est une solution en
l'occurrence ça serait très clair parce
que d'abord il y a un paquet relatif à
la révision de la législation
pharmaceutique qui a été présentée la
semaine dernière je vous laisse prendre
connaissance du texte mais il va porter
des avancées qui sont qui sont
intéressantes ensuite je pense pas qu'il
y ait eu qu'il y a eu d'injonctions
contradictoire au niveau européen quand
on a dû acheter des vaccins à l'Europe
était là quand on a dû acquérir des
médicaments innovants l'Europe était là
je parle du covid la question de l'accès
aux médicaments en Europe est plus
complexe parce qu'il y a derrière la
question de la prise en charge
financière et là-dessus en France on a
un peu un atout quand même c'est qu'on a
une super
protection sociale et que on arrive à
donner en accessible des médicaments qui
ne sont pas forcément chez ça chez
certains de nos voisins voilà moi je
crois vraiment à l'Europe comme étant
source de solutions plutôt que de
problèmes
vous dire aussi peut-être vous rappeler
des objectifs de la mission qui a été
lancé par la première ministre s'agit de
se pencher sur l'accès des patients aux
produits de santé ainsi que sur la
soutenabilité des dépenses de santé
autre problématique retrouve un objectif
de souveraineté sanitaire autrement dit
sera question d'étudier un renforcement
de la production de produits à la fois
innovants et essentiel il sera également
question de relocaliser la production
des produits de santé stratégique et de
travailler sur l'attractivité des
territoires pour les industriels du
secteur c'est tout un programme
sur les shortliners enfin en cas de
rupture la NSM interdit systématiquement
les exportations parallèles
ce n'est pas un sujet shortliner c'est
le modèle de l'exportation parallèle qui
peut concerner tous les grossistes
l'exportation parallèle n'est pas
interdite par la loi on peut simplement
l'interdire en cas de rupture ce que
fait systématiquement la NSM après
l'action de savoir si lorsque c'est
interdit certains de respectent pas
l'interdiction faut poser la question à
la NSM il faut agir plus sur
l'exportation parallèle il faut une
mesure communautaire car précisément ce
serait une atteinte au marché
aux livres échanges européen
rapidement
elle est constaté chez nous dire qu'elle
est elle peut pas être anticipée elle
est
c'est quand il y a une rupture
d'approvisionnement que la NSM prend la
décision donc le temps qu'on récupère un
peu de stock et on
est ce que je veux dire à quel moment on
déclenche ce qu'on me dit c'est comme si
tu mesures communautaire si on va aller
plus loin c'est une mesure commune alors
c'est une mesure communautaire et c'est
la NSM qu'il prend chez nous je pense
qu'on vérifiera
une réponse écrite
c'est pas mal mais je reste passionné
par la santé
c'est la dernière salle de question
nous avons auditionné ce matin donc la
ministre Rosine Bachelot qui a dit que
c'était une mauvaise décision pardon
décision la fermeture de les Prusse
votre point de vue sur
ce sujet non on n'est pas hors champ
parce que les Prusse se gèrent des
stocks et notamment en matière de
pénurie des Prusse aurait pu être en
capacité de gérer les stocks notamment
stratégique et donc je pense que voilà
c'est une question c'est pas hors champ
du tout
ce qui n'est pas hors champ non plus
c'est la question de la liste des
essentielles puisqu'on a 3000 MITM et
que donc voilà on s'orienterait vers une
liste alors peut-être national
européenne très probablement pour le
coup puisque les mains se Pench
sérieusement sur la question
quel est votre point de vue sur ce sujet
parce que la Constitution la liste des
MITM avait fait appel à toutes les
sociétés savantes et voilà on était
arrivé à 3000 pensez-vous faisable qu'on
descendait une liste de 200 100 à 200
parce que c'est vrai que si on doit
avoir des mesures particulières
évidemment il faut mieux que la liste
soit restreinte pour amener un maximum
de contrats et sécuriser
l'approvisionnement sur la question des
médicaments matures et des prix parce
que en fait c'est le gros sujet des
médicaments y compris certains
anticancéreux comme 5 fleurolier en ce
moment
cette question des pénuries concerne ces
médicaments matures on est quand même
par exemple les initiateurs de la non
pas proton on est à la septième baisse
de prix des IPP et donc à un moment même
si je comprends qu'il y a le secret des
affaires et que etc etc il y a quand
même un moment où je pense que enfin
je vous demande votre point de vue sur
ce sujet mais on doit bien mettre un
plancher ça peut pas être acceptable de
baisser à ce point des médicaments dont
le service médicalement rendu est
certain
s'ils ne sont plus là demain
[Musique]
les IPP en tout cas on risque d'avoir un
gros sujet la question du coût des
pénuries c'est une question à laquelle
on a aucune réponse et pour le coup on
parle de dépenses de santé donc dame de
PLFSS et il y a un coût alors il y a le
coup humain évidemment avec les retards
ou les renoncements au traitement les
retards thérapeutiques et avec les
anticancéreuses c'est ce qu'on va vous
c'est qu'on commence à voir très
certainement mais il y a un coût
financier c'est-à-dire que le
remplacement les bios les médicaments
similaires ou de remplacement sont
souvent plus chers à l'hôpital quand on
renégocie parce que un appel d'offres on
n'est plus dans le cadre de l'appel
d'offre justement et donc les
laboratoires ou même même s'il y a un
laboratoire de seconde ligne il est plus
cher que celui de première ligne quand
il a été choisi et donc l'estimation de
ses coups
est nécessaire et pour le coup
[Musique]
ça pourrait être quand même dans les
prérogatifs de nos différentes instances
qui se penchent sur la question de
pouvoir estimer le coût des pénuries
parce que on discute on discute de pfss
et l'ondame en ayant pas la main sur une
grosse part des règles du jeu et pour le
coup le coup des pénuries et
certainement très important et enfin on
est quand même il y a eu un rapport de
Liga ce qui est sorti de retour
d'expérience pendant de la covid que
vous aviez demandé je reviens sur cette
question d'organisation de la
commitologie et du pilotage des
politiques de santé c'est aussi une des
remarques qui a été faite par les gars
c'est même une grosse remarque puisqu'il
y a pas mal de d'intervention sur cette
question c'est la liste importante des
intervenants et la question du pilotage
et politique de santé et on voit que sur
les pénuries de médicaments on est dans
la même situation en réalité on a un
problème de de pilotage beaucoup de nos
intervenants on fait cette réflexion y
compris les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
et on voit bien qu'il y ait un pilotage
et donc quel est votre point de vue
là-dessus est-ce que ça pourrait être
une prérogative du ministère de la Santé
d'être le pilote unique il peut y avoir
des délégations de rôle de tâches des
responsabilités diverses et variées ils
n'empêche que quand on voit qu'il y a
une pénurie de
corticoïdes pour les nourrissons lors de
l'épisode de concurriture hivernal
depuis à peu près une dizaine d'années
on peut pas dire qu'on soit tout à fait
dans une situation critique mais on est
plutôt dans la situation chronique d'une
crise qui se renouvelle tous les ans
je vous remercie
clairement c'est un supportable pour les
Français que de ne pas trouver les
médicaments dont ils ont besoin c'est
peut-être encore plus insupportable
quand il s'agit d'enfants et j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages pendant la période
hivernale de famille qui ne comprenaient
pas que dans un pays comme la France on
ne trouve pas le médicament prescrit par
le pédiatre
rien à redire à ça rien à ça on a essayé
d'expliquer devant la discuter pendant
pendant une heure et demie ici de ce qui
a pu je dirais participer à creuser les
pénuries et peut-être élaborer quelques
pistes pour pouvoir y remédier à
l'avenir tout en se disant bien que le
problème est éminemment compliqué qu'il
est mondial certainement pas
franco-français et qu'il appelle avoir
une stratégie à mon sens européenne
pour les corticoïdes euroapie fabrique
le principe actif des corticoïdes
c'est-à-dire que le problème en tout cas
il n'est pas français puisque ces
produits vous avez eu des
surconsommation sur certains médicaments
avec des pics je crois plus 15%
de corticoïdes enfin je veux dire c'est
un sujet qui est quand même on est
d'accord
plusieurs questions que vous posez sur
la question de les Prusse en fait je
disais c'est hors champs non pas dans le
champ non pas dans la question de de la
mission qui nous occupe mais
dans le sens dans le sens où en fait les
prix n'a pas été supprimé dans le sens
où les missions étaient transférées
autant sur la gestion de crise en tant
que telle ça peut discuter autant là
l'établissement pharmaceutique il est
hébergé au sein des SPF c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui a permis d'acheter de faire de
passer les commandes de vaccins c'est
que le établissement pharmaceutique qui
relevait de les Prusse soit au sein de
de SPF et ce qui a permis aussi non
seulement les acheter mais des
distribués donc je pense pas que là
dessus ce soit un handicap on pourra en
discuter peut-être sur la la gestion de
crise sanitaire en général et sur la
capacité du de préparation pré-crise à
savoir ce qui était le procès reproche
qui avait pu être fait c'est est-ce que
le fait d'avoir supprimé des Prusse n'a
pas fait baisser un peu la garde j'en
suis pas sûr mais en tout cas en matière
médicament honnêtement je considère que
le transfert de l'établissement
pharmaceutique à SPF était la notion
essentielle
sur les MITM je voulais dire en
introduction il y a une mission qui a
été lancée annoncée par François Braun
et Roland Lescure en vue de réviser
cette liste je souhaite je suis
absolument pas compétent pour me
prononcer pour savoir si il faut
je suis pas étonné qui en est beaucoup
parce que si vous posez la question d'un
médecin il vous aurez toujours que les
médicaments dont il a besoin pour ces
malades sont essentiels et je leur en
ferai pas reproche mais donc il y a une
révision qui est en cours de ce point
sur la baisse des prix de certains
médicaments bah moi quand j'étais pardon
mais à nouveau je prends l'expérience de
terrain les imiteurs de pompe à protons
en fonction de l'éditeur de pompe à
protons que j'utilisais en neurologie
vasculaire le prix était pas du tout le
même d'ailleurs comme pour les statines
parce qu'il y a certains médicaments qui
passent qu'ils étaient considérés comme
un peu plus innovants allez vous êtes
facturé très cher et les études dans les
métiers dans les dans les pour les
maladies étaient faites en utilisant
uniquement ces médicaments là et pas les
formules un peu plus anciennes et donc
vous retrouvez un peu des fois avec le
sentiment de devoir prescrit un truc qui
coûte plus cher donc vous n'êtes pas
vous n'avez pas on vous a pas
complètement apporté la preuve que les
cartes de prix étaient justifié c'est là
qu'intervient ce qu'on appelle le SMS la
SMR pour pouvoir déterminer au plus
juste mais encore une fois le fait qu'il
y ait des baisses de prix sur des
médicaments qui sont à la fois l'usage
courant génériques etc ne me choque pas
la paire de rentabilisation du
médicament elle est passée ça reste
encore rentable un générique les
laboratoires qu'on investi massivement
la production générique il se plaignent
pas de ça mais ça ne me choque pas du
tout qu'un médicament qu'on utilise
depuis 20 ou 30 ans il est 7 8 9 10
baisse de prix c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet parce que dans leur modèle
économique ils tiennent compte du fait
qu'un médicament il va avoir 10 ans
d'exploitation lucrative et qu'après ça
ça leur rapportera un peu moins mais
qu'ils auront pu investir dans la R&D
pour préparer les médicaments qui vont
suivre ce qui change et ce qui ce à quoi
on est percuté aujourd'hui c'est le
changement de modèle je le redis entre
les médicaments comme les IPP ou les
statines etc qui étaient produits comme
et ces médicaments très onéreux produits
par thérapie génique sur des cibles plus
petites et donc avec un potentiel de
rentabilité moins important et c'est en
fait un peu ça si vous avez auditionné à
l'afficheur il en parlerait bien mieux
que je le ferai parce qu'il avait des
chiffres qui montraient que l'évolution
du financement des médicaments innovants
va nous mettre vraiment vraiment dans le
à l'échelle mondiale dans peu de temps
et je viens de croire le coût de la
pénurie
c'est très compliqué objectiver c'est
une bonne question
par chance en France on ne se pose pas
déjà la question du coup en tout cas
c'est pas un frein pour conduire
l'action après c'est important c'est
intéressant de se poser la question le
pilotage c'est l'ANSM en tout cas
au quotidien c'est l'agence qui gère
l'interface avec les acteurs
pour la gouvernance de la pénurie 1
cette fois-ci qui doit qui doit gérer
cela donc en mon sens le paysage des
agences il est assez clair la NSM elle a
quand même c'est une agence qui
fonctionne très bien et qui est dotée de
ses prérogatives et ensuite la question
l'interministérialité c'est une autre
question du bonne question en gros
est-ce que c'est la santé ou est-ce que
c'est Bercy qui gère les médicaments bah
écoutez les deux mon capitaine mais en
tout cas je me suis bien entendu avec
Bercy pour qu'on soit à la fois capable
de demander des baisses de prix sur des
vieux médicaments à la fois de mettre
sur le marché des médicaments très
innovants comme le castria et à la fois
être capable avec Bercy et à la demande
du président d'investir massivement dans
l'industrie pharma du futur à travers
France relance ou France 2030 je pense
que c'est un équilibre c'est aussi
l'équilibre qu'on trouve généralement
dans le budget de la Sécurité sociale
avec le pôle Bercy et le pôle santé
c'est important que ceux qui dépensent
et ce qui
finance soit autour de la table au sein
du gouvernement
de petits colères par rapport à ce que
vous avez dit parce que effectivement
quand on est allé visiter donc ces 15 ce
que nous a dit le PDG en fait c'est que
pour les 100 produits critiques
c'était pas ça ne coûtait pas beaucoup
d'argent que de relocaliser parce que
les usines étaient
multiproduits bien sûr il s'agissait de
d'avoir une capacité de modernisation
d'adaptation des usines mais c'était
tout à fait possible donc il faut la
volonté politique évidemment et puis
aussi s'appuyer sur sur des entreprises
qui en ont aussi la volonté c'était ma
première remarque sur les prix puisque
plusieurs de mes collègues sont venus
dessus on a été choqué aujourd'hui quand
on a
auditionné les groupements d'achat
hospitaliers l'uni ha et puis résa
d'apprendre que malgré leur souhait elle
n'avait aucun un lien avec le CEPS et
c'est tout à fait dommageable donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles n'ont pas de
lien est-ce qu'elles peuvent pas
collaborer voilà et la troisième chose
que je voulais vous dire puisque on
était sur une en s'appuyant sur la gepse
sur quelques produits critiques donc là
on parle de d'une centaine maximum etc
reprendre la main public lui dire d'une
production publique hors or crise mais
toujours sur avec des problèmes de
tension la feuille de route que vous
avez piloté elle elle disait notamment
la nécessité d'expertiser la mise en
place d'une solution publique pour
organiser des approvisionnements en cas
de pénurie avérées
donc est-ce que vous en avez fait le
bilan puisque à la fois vous nous dites
dans votre propos introductif que à
Jette etc donc est-ce que vous en avez
fait un bilan qui vous permet
effectivement de soutenir
cette proposition en dehors d'une crise
avérée
ou pas alors
d'abord sur ces coins je ferais pas de
commentaires sur l'analyse qui a été
faite par l'industriel en revanche j'ai
été présent c'était avec Jean Castex je
crois à Lyon pour l'ouverture d'une
usine Sanofi qui permet de faire sur une
ligne de production multi-produits en
matière vaccination et d'être capable de
switcher pour fabriquer etc donc cette
fluidité cette flexibilité ce qui est
passé d'intervertir un des produits
qu'on va fabriquer je pense que ça c'est
l'avenir sur l'échelle de production de
médicaments en tout cas ça fait partie
de l'avenir sur le lien entre ni achat
donc entre les centrales d'achat groupé
et le CEPS pourquoi est-ce qu'il devrait
avoir un lien en fait parce que le CEPS
il est là pour déterminer avec
l'industriel le prix auquel sera
remboursé un médicament en fonction du
service médical rendu et de
l'amélioration du service médical rendu
d'accord notamment en tenant compte
d'autres critères et ensuite une achat
c'est une Centrale qui va acheter les
médicaments pour les fournir aux
établissements je vois pas quel est le
je vois pas pourquoi intervenir la
centrale d'achat en fait ce sont les
mêmes fournisseurs ce sont les
laboratoires donc qui fournissent à
l'hôpital ou qui fournissent à la
médecine de génie sont concernés par le
stock au global
ce qui est bonne acteur ils sont en lien
lui des centrales d'achat avec avec des
Jos c'est les prix des médicaments
hospitaliers qui sont dans les tarifs
ils font pas l'objet d'une fixation par
le par le CEPS non mais je
et dernière question je l'ai boulotter
pardon je sais plus ce que vous m'aviez
ah oui sur l'évaluation de la feuille de
route alors ça c'est pas à moi de le
faire c'est au ministre de la Santé en
charge parce que la feuille de route
était encore en cours quand j'ai quand
j'ai quitté mes fonctions
je sais pas si vous avez prévu le
dictionnaire oui
et sur la solution publique j'ai dit en
introduction que je retiens la crise
covid
vous comprendrez que pour qu'il relève
du système de santé à venir cette au
ministre de la Santé de se prononcer sur
cette question
merci monsieur le ministre je sais pas
si vous avez d'autres éléments que vous
voulez porter un autre connaissance
merci beaucoup en tout cas
en tout cas merci pour ces éléments de
réponse